Muy buenas tardes José Manuel fue al
castillo de Ruth esto es al este del
país muy cerca de la frontera con Suiza
allí depositó una ofrenda floral y dio
un discurso como usted bien lo decía en
honor a tu salud Quién era él como usted
bien lo decía si padre la independencia
de Haití él nació en la isla de Santo
Domingo en el siglo 18 que después
terminó convirtiéndose en Haití
precisamente de padres de esclavos él
fue esclavo pero logró ser libre en 1776
fue ganando bastante poder en la isla y
apoyó una revuelta por parte de los
Esclavos allí tanto así que terminó
convirtiéndose en el capitán general en
la isla ese será el cargo el segundo
cargo más importante y fue nombrado así
por Napoleón Bonaparte sin embargo en
realidad quería emanciparse un poco de
ese poder central y Esto llevó a que
fuera apresado por el mismo Napoleón
Bonaparte traído aquí a Francia y
encarcelado en ese castillo de Ruth
donde hoy Emanuel dio este discurso en
honor a este héroe y además Pues que a
través de la figura del la posibilidad
también de rendir homenaje a las
víctimas de la esclavitud a los
abolicionistas y también a los héroes en
este caso pues obviamente este este esta
figura emblemática de la lucha por la
libertad de la lucha contra la
esclavitud así fue como se desarrolló
toda esta ceremonia digamos
prácticamente casi en tranquilidad pero
lo cierto Es que como ustedes bien lo
saben les hemos venido contando que cada
desplazamiento del presidente y de sus
ministros siempre pues se ve digamos
torpedeado por manifestantes y fue el
caso también allí en este lugar varias
decenas de manifestantes esperaban al
presidente Emmanuel